>>> WELCOME BACK TO "CBS THIS
MORNING."
CBS NEWS HAS BEEN INVESTIGATING
TROUBLING EVIDENCE OF DRUG USE
AND CRIMINALITY IN THE RANKS OF
THE NAVY S.E.A.L.s.
CATHERINE HERRIDGE SPOKE TO
FORMER AND CURRENT S.E.A.L.s
THAT WANT TO REMAIN ANONYMOUS.
TODAY IN PART TWO, WE HEAR HOW
SOME CAPITALIZED ON THE RAID
THAT KILLED OSAMA BIN LADEN TEN
YEARS AGO THIS WEEKEND.
CATHERINE HERRIDGE JOINS US NOW.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
WHAT HAVE YOU LEARNED?
>> WE SAT DOWN WITH FORMER AND
ACTIVE DUTY S.E.A.L.s THAT SAID
THE VAST MAJORITY SERVE WITH
HONOR, A SELECT FEW CASHED IN ON
THE BRAND.
KILLING OSAMA BIN LADEN TEN
YEARS AGO WAS CELEBRATED IN THE
STREETS.
THE OPERATION BY S.E.A.L. TEAM 6
BROUGHT A KIND OF CELEBRITY THAT
WAS AT ODDS WITH TRADITION OF
BEING A QUIET PROFESSIONAL.
>> THEY SHOULD NEVER HAVE SAID
NAVY S.E.A.L.s DID THIS.
>> ERIC DEMING SPENT 20 YEARS AS
A S.E.A.L., DID TOURS IN IRAQ
AND AFGHANISTAN.
>> I HATE BEING IN THIS CHAIR
TALKING TO YOU NOW.
I DON'T KNOW IF THIS IS GOING TO
HELP.
AT LEAST IT WILL EXPOSE THE
PROBLEM.
AND I AM HOPING THIS ENCOURAGES
GOOD S.E.A.L.s TO START SAYING
ENOUGH IS ENOUGH.
>> THESE S.E.A.L.s, INCLUDING
RETIRED AND ACTIVE DUTY AGREED
TO SPEAK WITH CBS NEWS ON THE
CONDITION VOICES WERE CHANGED
AND IDENTITIES CONCEALED.
>> IF WE HAD NEVER KNOWN
S.E.A.L.s TOOK OUT OSAMA BIN
LADEN, YOU BELIEVE THE S.E.A.L.
COMMUNITY WOULD BE IN A BETTER
PLACE TODAY.
>> YES.
>> ONE OF THE FIRST THOUGHTS IN
MY MIND WAS HOW LONG ARE WE
GOING TO GO BEFORE SOMEBODY
EXPLOITS THIS FOR PERSONAL GAIN.
AND WE DIDN'T HAVE TO WAIT LONG.
>> HOLLYWOOD TOLD THE STORY OF
THE RAID IN THE FILM "ZERO DARK
30."
AND CBS AIRED FOUR SEASONS OF
ITS OWN PRIME TIME SERIES "SEAL
TEAM."
THEY MONETIZED NEW FOUND FAME.
>> AUTOGRAPHED PHOTOS WE BOUGHT
ONLINE.
WHY ARE YOU SHAKING YOUR HEAD?
>> I DON'T WANT TO TOUCH IT.
>> IT IS NOT OKAY?
>> WHAT ABOUT THE QUIET
PROFESSIONAL DOES THAT
ENCOMPASS, NONE OF IT.
>> MEMBERS OF S.E.A.L. TEAM 6
WERE DISCIPLINED FOR BEING PAID
CONSULTANTS TO A VIDEOGAME
COMPANY.
>> WHAT'S THE PROBLEM?
>> EXPOSING TACTICS, TECHNIQUES,
PROCEDURES.
THEY EXPOSED ALL KINDS OF THINGS
OF HOW WE OPERATE.
>> ANOTHER PUNISHED FOR WRITING
AN UNAUTHORIZED ACCOUNT OF THE
RAID.
>> IT IS NOT EVERYBODY DOING IT.
MOST GUYS ON S.E.A.L. TEAMS WANT
BOOKS TO STOP, MOVIES TO STOP,
TV SHOWS TO STOP.
>> WHY SHOULDN'T THEY MAKE MONEY
WHEN THEY'RE FINISHED?
P>> THIS ISN'T GOING TO HARVARD
FOR A BUSINESS DEGREE, YOU SERVE
TO UPHOLD THE CONSTITUTION OF
THE UNITED STATES AND PROTECT
OUR COUNTRY.
THE MILITARY AND OUR OPERATIONS,
THEY'RE NOT FOR SALE.
>> WE ASKED S.E.A.L.s WHY
THEY'RE SPEAKING OUT.
>> THERE IS DESPERATION TO PUT
IT IN THREE WORDS, WE NEED HELP.
AND THAT'S WHY WE ARE HERE.
>> TOP S.E.A.L. COMMANDER
DECLINED AN INTERVIEW REQUEST,
PROVIDED A STATEMENT THAT
MIRRORED HIS TESTIMONY TO
CONGRESS WEDNESDAY.
>> I PRESENT OUR UPDATE TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WITH HUMILITY.
HUMILITY SHARPENED IN COMBAT
LOSSES AND PERFECTION.
A HUMILITY THAT DRIVES A SENSE
OF URGENCY TO LEARN, EVOLVE, AND
COME BACK STRONGER AND MORE
COMMITTED TO MISSIONS OUR NATION
ASKS OF US.
>> WHAT'S IT GOING TO TAKE TO
CONVICTION THE PROBLEM?
>> IT IS GOING TO TAKE GOOD GUYS
ON THE TEAMS STAYING THERE,
FIGHTING THE GOOD FIGHT, CALLING
THEM OUT, AND SOME OUTSIDE
ENTITY COMING IN AND DOING A
FULL REVIEW OF EVERYTHING.
IT HAS TO COME FROM OUTSIDE AND
IT HAS TO BE SOMEBODY THAT'S GOT
SOME INTEGRITY.
>> DEMMING WHO FILED THE
COMPLAINT OVER TRAINING
PRACTICES STILL CARRIES THE
TRIDENT FROM HIS DAYS AS A
S.E.A.L.
WITHOUT CHANGE, DEMMING
SHATTERED HIS OWN CHILD'S
DREAMS.
>> YOU WOULDN'T LET YOUR OWN SON
JOIN THE S.E.A.L.s?
>> I WOULDN'T.
>> WAS IT A HARD CONVERSATION
WITH YOUR SON?
>> CRUSHING.
>> AND WHAT COMES NEXT MAY BE
MORE SIGNIFICANT.
THE PENTAGON INSPECTOR GENERAL
HAS BEGUN AN EVALUATION INTO
POTENTIAL WAR CRIMES, AND
WHETHER SPECIAL OPERATIONS,
WHICH INCLUDES THE S.E.A.L.s,
HAS DONE ENOUGH TO REPORT WAR
CRIMES ON THE BATTLEFIELD.
>> ANOTHER POWERFUL STORY,
ESPECIALLY THE MOMENT WHEN HE
WOULDN'T WANT HIS SON TO JOIN
THE S.E.A.L.s.
>> YOU COULD TELL HE WAS VERY
EMOTIONAL.
STILL VERY UPSETTING TO HIM.
I AM GLAD THEY'RE SPEAKING UP
THOUGH.
WE SAID THIS YESTERDAY, THEY'RE
TELLING THE STORY.
IT IS A STORY PEOPLE NEED TO
HEAR.
VERY IMPORTANT.
>> YOUNG PEOPLE THINKING ABOUT
THE S.E.A.L.s WILL SEE AN
INTERVIEW LIKE THAT AND BE
INTERESTED MORE SO THAN WHEN
THEY SEE PRIME TIME DRAMA.
>> I WANT TO HEAR WHAT THE
PEOP